for centuries the iron throne had no
more loyal ally than the princes of
dorne
since we had never fallen to them we
kept our ancestral title
perhaps this is what drew rhaegar
targaryen to us
his royal parents had not produced a
sister for him to wait so he had to look
elsewhere for a princess
and there was only one in westeros
elya of house martell
my sister
she was not the most beautiful woman in
the world or even in dorne
but
rare for a woman from our land her
flower came with no thorns
she was kind and clever with a gentle
heart
i loved her i feared for her
for years i fended off lesser men from
her
but when rhaegar came even i failed
he was beautiful and the ground prince
of the seven kingdoms and our mother had
worked so hard to secure the match how
could elia not accept him
they were wed and he took her from her
home from those who loved her and would
die for her and locked her in his red
keep above his sky of a city surrounded
by false friends
she bore him a daughter and a son though
each almost cost her her life
elia loved rhaegar
she obeyed him
and he chose to steal away leanna stark
a pale northern girl whose veins ran
with ice like all her people
instead of disciplining his faithless
son king aerys executed the starks when
they came seeking justice and ignited a
revolt
i know how the maesters describe the war
now but calling it robert's rebellion
does not change what it was
the war of the usurper
dorne sided with the crown for when we
swear oaths we keep them we needed no
threats from king aerys though he made
them anyway locking elya and her
children in the red keep to ensure our
loyalty
even in his madness he knew that no true
dornishmen would ever take up arms
against our beloved princess
and that we would fight to the death for
whichever side she was on
a plan was devised prince rhaegar would
personally lead the royal forces now
reinforced with ten thousand dornishmen
north to face robert of the king's guard
lou and mattel and i would ride with the
prince
at the trident dorne lost ten thousand
men and two princes
my uncle in the king's guard and elias
gallant husband
prince rhaegar who was too slow or too
arrogant for robert's war hammer
as robert's army marched on king's
landing the mad king sent his own wife
and child away but kept my sister and
hers inside
in his madness aerys thought that the
dornish had betrayed his son at the
trident and was only too happy to
welcome his one true friend back into
his ranks
tywin
lannister
lord tywin's army sacked his friend's
city while lord tywin's son murdered the
king he'd sworn to protect
all this could have been forgiven
war is terrible and men must become
terrible to wage it
but the lannisters knew that as long as
my sister and her children prince
rhaegar's heirs lived no usurper could
safely sit the throne
so lord tywin's dog sir gregor clegane
the mountain made ellie a watch as he
murdered her daughter and dashed her
infant son's head against a wall
then with her baby's blood still on his
hands and murdered her
when lord tywin later presented their
bodies to robert baratheon wrapped in
pretty lannister cloaks
i have been told the red color
graciously hid the blood from men's eyes
the targaryen stalk of fire and blood
in dorne our blood is
fire
if robert baratheon had dared set foot
in dorne during his reign he would have
lost the foot
when i was a boy of 16 a great lord
caught me with his mistress
he should have been honored
instead the fat old fool challenged me
to a duel
thanks to my age and status only to
first blood
but his mistress and his wife warned me
which of my parts he intended to draw
first blood from
he was strong and fierce but slow i cut
him quickly and the duel ended with
honor satisfied
then his wounds festered and he died
ever since men have called me the red
viper
a name that never fails to draw laugh
from me
as if a single serpent was all i knew of
venom
westeros has mighty rivers but none of
them compare to the roy it is said that
there is no stream or puddle in western
esses but drains to mother roy
no doubt an exaggeration
until one sees the river at its widest a
man in the center can't see ashore to
either side the greatest of mother roy's
children were the ruiner a civilization
as ancient and grand as old geese
fishers traders scholars workers of
woods stone and metal the ruiner raised
their elegant cities from the headwaters
of the royne down to her mouth each
lovelier than the last for many
centuries the ruiner lived in relative
peace when invaders swept down from the
hills the ruiner women and men would don
silver-scaled armor fish head helms tall
spears and turtle shell shields
if the enemy did not laugh themselves
away it was said that mother royne would
whisper the enemy's secrets to her
children and the rhoynish wizards could
raise watery walls to drown their foes
whatever magic the ruiner may have had
it wasn't enough when valyrian colonists
first arrived the ruiner embraced them
for all men were welcome to share the
bounty of mother roy
perhaps a water people should have been
more cautious of strangers who exalted
fire and blood
legend has it that one day the valyrians
netted and butchered one of the giant
turtles the ruiner held sacred as a
result thousands were killed or enslaved
cities and towns were burned drowned and
rebuilt in these wars the valerians
emerged as victorious more often than
not the princes of the roiny cities
fiercely proud of their independence
fought alone whilst the valyrian
colonies aided one another
eventually the rhoynish princess ceased
their squabbling and united behind
prince garan who led the largest army
essas had ever seen against a hundred
thousand valyrian colonists a hundred
war elephants and three dragon lords
thousands burned but thousands more
sheltered in the shallows of the river
whilst the rhinish wizards raised
enormous water spouts against the foes
dragons
rhoynish archers brought down two of the
dragons whilst the third fled wounded
and thereafter the ruiner named garen
the great
but mother valyria proved just as caring
as mother roy when garen the great
marched his army against volantis 300
valyrian dragons descended from the sky
tens of thousands burned whilst others
rushed into the river but the fires
burned so hot that the water boiled and
turned to steam
garen the great was captured alive and
made to watch as valyrians butchered
every last man so many that their blood
turned the great harbour of atlantis red
as far as the eye could see
then they forced garen to watch as they
marched on his own city and enslaved all
the women and children his army had left
behind the singers claimed that prince
garan called out mother roin to curse
the valyrians and she in turn flooded
the city with foul waters and a damp fog
that caused the skin of the valyrians to
harden and crack and thus was born grey
scale
fearing a similar fate another rhoynish
ruler princess nymeria led her own
people into every ship skiff and raft
they had and fled essos eventually after
much hardship they landed in sunswept
and bone-dry dawn
but we all know that tale
she was lucky to land in dorne where
powerful women are not locked away in
seps and the beds of old men
my ancestor maurice martell saw her and
desired her and proved that where armies
fail a tongue may succeed
wedding his strength to hers his spear
to her son they subdued all his rivals
together
after the tradition of her people house
martel then ruled dorne as princes not
kings
unless the eldest child was a daughter
for unlike the rest of westeros we
follow a prince or a princess martel
just the same and we always have
some people forget that aegon targaryen
crowned himself lord of six kingdoms not
seven
when his sister marched on dorne she
found no mighty hosts drawn up against
her for her dragon to burn in her
soldiers to slaughter
the sands swirled men died and her
dragon saw nothing
the sun shone men died and her dragon
bowed to our greater fire
the targaryens retreated with their
tails tucked between their legs
of course in later years his descendants
would try again
deyron the first succeeded at great cost
and reigned in dorne for a few glorious
months
one night his steward pulled down a sash
by his bed to summon his consorts
instead the canopy split open and a
hundred red scorpions fell on him
he was a tyrell you would think he would
be used to getting stung
within a fortnight house martel again
ruled a free door